[Music]
you know we've been doing something
lately I've been I've been playing and
reviewing popular video games as a
service for our viewers for my latest
review we had our fans pick the game we
asked them what do you want me to review
well most of the fans unanimously said
you've got to tackle the super popular
video game Minecraft alright yes I had
not experienced minecraft before I sat
down got a little help and here's my
review we asked you guys what game do
you want me to rate and you said
minecraft my friend Erin Blair and I are
going to play Minecraft I don't play
video games I'm not kidding I don't know
anything about this I know nothing about
it I thought this was one of those neck
massager from Brookstone this game is
all about mining things and then
building things taking things out of the
ground then building things correct
right so so it's like we're in Wales in
the 19th century and we're desperately
poor what a fun game for kids every game
starts in a randomly generated world all
right so so you can walk around we're
like in a forest yeah I'm going through
some grass with a pole with travel the
boy there's a pig I don't think you see
me yeah yes you yeah hey why not we're
in plaid pants this is the only guy with
the orange hair so we kind of made you
so the guy with the orange hair we're
stupid madras boxer shorts that's
discriminatory look even the sheep the
sheep just gave me a look like what's
with that
the black sheep keep checking me out and
the other guy that molested me last
night
alright so we find nothing all right so
follow me over here we're gonna get some
wood all right so follow me they put no
effort into the graphics this looks like
a world if you have glaucoma it should
be called the cloud cover world the
pressure in your eyeball is too high
your vision is so impaired you put on
madras shorts and you don't know it yet
sheep just keep sniffing let's get out
of here get out see
okay let's chop something down but God's
sake okay nothing's happened we've grown
poorer and older oh I'm not your potato
you dig into the ground - I keep digging
into the ground enough you know I fled
Ireland to not do this at nighttime
monsters come out sir monsters yeah and
they kill us so uh monsters coming this
way those are scary monsters my
six-year-old could draw a better monster
than that that's a skeleton that shoots
bows and arrows no I'm not saying yeah
all right we're gonna make a run for
this house real quick go bleh all right
where the hell is a house all right okay
we got in the house anymore awkwardly -
guys
you're noticing my shorts his bow just
gotta watch total Excel walk target Oh
is there a admirer say once in college
so what would you rate this ski she's
not gonna be nice
minecraft which I understand is very
popular very popular today so young
people that really can't see well let's
do it people have never seen when a real
house looks like and then like
depressing climates I'm still confused I
don't know what we accomplished I don't
know why the monsters were so good with
bow and arrows confused about that I
mean they're monsters that you just rip
your head off what I have bows and
arrows out of an 88 and eighty-eight
being pretty good
110 being excellent a 150 being awful
three being
not bad I would give this let's say a 26
see make yourself a Minecraft please go
to the nearest lens crafter get fitted
for some eyeglasses
[Music]
that's helpful you can see the other
video games I've reviewed at team
koco.com slash clueless gamer you should
check with me before you make this very
expensive purchase
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]